in Poland have grown even closer this
year is our nation's mark 100 years of
diplomatic relations the u.s. polish
alliance is stronger by far than ever
before
earlier today president Duda and I
signed a joint declaration affirming the
significant defense cooperation between
our nation's and as the declaration
makes very clear the United States and
Poland are not only bound by a strategic
partnership but by deep common values
shared goals and a very strong and
abiding friendship our people are united
by the enduring ties of civilization
culture and history we respect the rule
of law
Revere individual rights and prized our
timeless traditions we embrace country
faith family and freedom over the past
century brave American and polish
Patriots have repeatedly stood together
to defend our sovereignty our liberty
and our noble way of life when I was
last in Paul and I was very proud to
stand among veterans of the Warsaw
Uprising and recall their incredible
courage in the face of Nazi tyranny
today we honor the sacrifices of all
those who came before by doing our part
to safeguard our independence and
strengthen the incredible us Polish
alliance as stated in the joint
declaration the United States and Poland
continued to enhance our security
cooperation Poland will still provide
basing and infrastructure to support
military presence of about 1,000
American troops the Polish government
will build these projects at no cost to
the United States the Polish government
will pay for this we thank president
Duda and the people of Poland for their
partnership in advancing our common
security Poland's burden-sharing
also extends to the NATO alliance where
it is among eight NATO allies including
the United States currently meeting the
minimum 2% of GDP that's for defense
spending and Poland's
there and you've been there from a very
early data we appreciate that very much
and we've been there also there's been a
total of 8 8 out of 28 the rest are
coming along because nations at my
urging have paid more than 100 billion
dollars more toward the NATO defense
last month I was very pleased that
Poland announced the intent to purchase
32 american-made f-35 fighter aircraft
like you just saw moments ago we
witnessed that impressive flyover of
this cutting-edge f-35 as it flew over
the White House and actually came to a
pretty close to a halt over the White
House I would say what's wrong with that
plane it's not going very fast but it's
an incredible it's an incredible thing
when you can do that the plane can land
dead straight and it's one of the few in
the world that can do that considered to
be the greatest fighter jet in the world
I applaud president Duda for its efforts
to strengthen and modernize Poland's
defenses I also want to congratulate
Poland for its progress on meeting u.s.
criteria for entry into the visa waiver
program today our country signed a
preventing and combating serious crimes
agreement a significant and necessary
step for Poland's entry into the program
though we still have some work to do we
hope to welcome Poland into the visa
waiver program very soon and that's a
very big deal both of our nations
understand that immigration security is
national security in our meeting
president Duda and I discussed the vital
issue of energy reliance on a single
foreign supplier of energy leaves
nations totally vulnerable to coercion
and extortion for this reason
we support Poland's construction of the
Baltic pipeline which will help European
countries diversify their energy sources
it's desperately needed and that's the
way to go during the past year Poland
has also signed approximately 25 billion
dollars worth of new contracts with US
firms to buy more than 6 billion cubic
meters of US liquefied natural gas today
our nation's just signed another
contract for an additional 2 billion
cubic meters worth approximately 8
billion dollars so between the planes
and the liquefied natural gas and many
other things that Poland is doing which
is doing very well because Poland is
doing very very well we appreciate it
thank you very much mr. president our
countries also signed an agreement to
expand us polish civil nuclear
cooperation which will likewise advance
Poland's energy and security and deepen
our bilateral commercial ties economic
relations between the u.s. and Poland
are thriving we're committed to further
expanding Commerce based on fairness and
reciprocity perhaps my favorite word
across many critical areas from defense
and diplomacy to energy and economics
the alliance between the United States
and Poland is reaching extraordinary new
heights in 2019
our long-standing partnership
demonstrates the enormous possibilities
for the world went to strong and
independent nations unite in common
purpose and in common cause President
Duda it's a honor to have you with us
and mrs. Duda thank you very much for
being here we usher in a very exciting
new era in u.s. polish alliance it's a
very special alliance with very special
people we build a future of promise and
prosperity for the American and the
Polish people and again our relationship
is an extraordinary one and it's going
to remain that for a long long time
thank you very much mr. president
[Applause]
here's a son of distinguished ministers
all distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen
first and foremost with my wife like to
thank you very much mr. president
Donald Trump thank you also to the First
Lady Melania Trump for this invitation
to Washington thank you for this
possibility of holding another with
indle eyes and months official visit to
the United States here at the White
House this clearly demonstrates how
close and how good contacts are today
between Poland and the United States mr.
president all of us hope that you will
visit us in Poland in September and that
we will be able together to commemorate
the memory of all those who fell and who
perished during the Second World War
which started on the 1st of September
1939 in Poland through the attack of
Nazi Germans on our country and soon
unfortunately our country vanished from
the map of Europe after the attack of
the Soviet Union against Poland together
with Nazi Germany that is our history
it's a very difficult one and today we
firmly believe that the true ally of
Poland but also a true ally of a free
Europe is precisely the United States of
America who helped that very Europe in
such a huge way to win the Second World
War and later to establish an
independent sovereign and free world
which later turned into the European
Union
it exists until this day and thanks God
also thanks to the support of the United
States through the support of subsequent
presidents since 1989 thanks to the
great movement of solidarity thanks to
the great determination of the Polish
nation also we are part of the three
free world
so Poland which liberated itself from
behind Iron Curtain which later led to
the collapse of errand curtain through
the votes of the people casting
elections in 1989 in those elections
people said no to the companies also
Poland can develop today as an
independent and truly sovereign country
a country which wants to build the
European Community and a country which
also wants to build the euro-atlantic
community in our understanding this is
an absolutely key element of peace and
good cooperation across the globe thank
you very much mr. president thank you
that for sure you are among those
presidents of the United States who
understand how it works perfectly
you understand that Europe when it looks
at the security of the European states
it plays a key role for the peace around
the globe it is of key importance for
the peaceful development of democratic
states and democratic communities Thank
You mr. president for this extreme
kindness towards Poland and perfect
understanding of Polish matters which
has showed to us in 2017 during your
visit to Poland during your memorable
speech that you gave at the monument of
the words of uprising where it's so
immensely important words for Polish
people fell which are of historic
importance to our nation and to Europe
they showed what Poland means and who
poles are mr. president thank you for
entering those words back then and think
you are also for this policy which is
being implemented right now which
demonstrates that you are this kind of
man and this kind of a politician who's
not always speaks but to whom first and
most important are the deeds most
important are the deeds and whenever you
say mr. president make America great
again means make not
precisely is of crucial importance hence
the agreement that we were signing hence
to agreement between our two states
concluded to date two memorandums of
understanding which we signed just a
moment ago one of them I signed
personally concerning the security and
military cooperation as you mentioned
sir there will be more American troops
in Poland this is going to be an
enhanced cooperation it's going to be an
enduring presence which hopefully will
increase gradually in terms of the
number of troops but also in terms of
infrastructure which is their importance
thank you also for the decision to
establish Division Headquarters in
Poland this is a few gence not only to
Poland but also to our part of Europe to
Central Europe to the Baltic States and
to all those to whom the enhanced
forward prisons was established of the
United States and other NATO States
along NATO's eastern flank I'm deeply
grateful for that but Thank You mr.
president also for the remaining
agreements thank you for this agreement
which agreement which talks about
preventing and combating serious crimes
it moves us closer to visa waiver
program between Poland and the United
States which to you mr. president and to
me and first infer mr. poles is so
important of such a crucial importance
Thank You mr. president
also for excellent energy cooperation
that we have in terms of LNG supplies we
talked about this in 2017 in Warsaw
during every meeting that gas from the
United States should be delivered to
Poland and it is delivered and we are
assigning more contracts and gas tankers
from the United States are coming to the
party she knows today and the gas from
the United States has become a fact in
Poland in every part of Europe Thank You
mr. president that there are going to be
more supplies I'm very happy about that
because to us it means diversification
of sources of supplies it also means the
development of gas security to us it
also means good business
justice I believe is a good business for
the United States of America but thank
you also for the agreement on
cooperation in terms of nuclear energy
used for civil purposes I hope that
together we will be able to implement
this program with the benefit for
Environment Protection with the benefit
for protection across the globe also for
the development of the security of my
homeland mr. president I'm deeply
grateful for this visit I'm pleased that
thanks to this prisons were able to show
the very good cooperation that we have
between pilatus part of the European
Union and the United States and I firmly
believe that thanks to your incredible
view of the European matters and thanks
to your understanding to our polish
matters and to the meanders of our
history this cooperation is going to
develop better and better
first and foremost also with the benefit
for the United States whose interests
you are representing mr. president also
understanding the rest of the world
thank you very much so that for that
thank you very much we'll take a few
questions
emerald o weigh in Thank You mr.
president thank you earlier in the oval
office before you did your meeting with
president Duda you were quite critical
of Germany as you talked about possibly
moving troops from Germany to Poland do
you think that doing a move like that
will put pressure on Germany to meet
their defence spending requirements no I
don't think so I just will tell you very
strongly than I think Germany is making
a tremendous mistake by relying so
heavily on the pipeline and I think it's
a tremendous mistake for Germany but
again Germany's running their affairs
and they'll do just fine but I was
critical I had been critical of it it's
a tremendous amount of their energy will
be supplied by that pipeline at the same
time having nothing to do with Germany
Poland said that we would like to build
a facility a great facility and would
like to have you come to that facility
so we're going to be there with a
limited force but we'll be there and we
appreciate Poland doing what they're
doing it's a great location it's a
tremendous
it's a tremendous plant tremendous
facility and we it's our honor to be
there Poland's been a tremendous friend
of ours for a long time and when Milani
and I were there not so long ago it was
a very special day I think it was a
special day for Poland also but it was a
very special day for our country so I
appreciate that and our relationship is
just a very strong one and if I may what
you enjoy to me with one more question
before I get in more recent news
yesterday you were billed you got
another letter from Kim jong-un and
today we hear of a potential thawing of
relations between South Korea North
Korea's Kim jong-un send his sister to
South Korea now could you give us an
update on more of what it was in that
letter and is there a third summit in
the works he just wrote me a very nice
letter unexpected and someday you'll see
what was in that letter someday you'll
be reading about it maybe in a hundred
years from now maybe in two weeks who
knows but it was a very nice letter it
was a very warm very nice letter I
appreciated it okay thank you good thank
you very much you said you were thankful
for the commitment that the president
made for more troops today but you
hinted that you would like to see more
ultimately what is the number of troops
that you'd like to see in Poland US
troops so upon your adductors after
bending to be the decision of the United
States of America troops absolutely
going to be up to the United States to
decide how many troops so we'll be sent
to Paul to which
allied nation of course I know that this
depends on the needs and of the real
situation on the ground of course we are
very pleased that a US troops are
present by giving an evidence to the
sustainability and strength of the
Alliance and the US soldiers are kindly
treated in Poland they are received
friends and we are happy that they are
serving in our country we would like
those bonds between Poland and the
United States to become even tighter and
we are trying also to create the best
possible conditions for American
soldiers Susanna Falls man thank you
very much
president Trump thank you very much
president Duda I have questions to both
of you actually
president Trump you plan to enhance US
military presence in Poland last year
you promised you would enhance our
military cooperation training
intelligence missile defense and it's
happening right now people of Poland
still remember your incredible speech in
Warsaw
why Poland is such an important ally for
you I just have a very warm feeling for
Poland I always have and it's now even
beyond that because of the relationship
which we've developed with your
president and first lady and it's just
they're very they're incredible people
hard-working smart very industrious
people and what they've done with the
country over the last five years has
been something that the world has
watched and the world has marveled at
I've just liked Poland so when the
president came and he has to be whether
or not we'd consider this I said I will
consider it and now because of his
leadership we're able to do that and
that's fine with me that's great great
people and say hello
sorry understand we will see you in
September in Warsaw correct we are
looking very seriously going back to
Poland and I don't know what the
president has in store for us but we're
thinking about going back sometime in
September
yes question to president Duda mr.
president so far we have been talking
about a rotational prisons of US troops
in our country right now we are talking
about and permanent or enduring presence
what does that mean in concrete terms
and when can we expect those additional
US troops to arrive
I understand it in the following way
president Trump and myself are
implementing very comb but consistent
policy in terms of security the prisons
of the United States in Poland the
military prisons the prisons of US
troops which today is about 4,500 troops
present on a permanent basis in other
words is rotational prisons but it is
back-to-back prisons so there is no
moment where there are no American
troops in the territory of Poland and
today we signed a document and further
cooperation joint accleration on defense
cooperation regarding United States is
first posture in the Republic of Poland
this is of a breakthrough character
because it moves us to another era so
far we can say that the Americans were
testing the situation in Poland how it
looks how it feel what about logistics
whether it is possible to stay in Poland
and to successfully attain the goals and
implement the tasks of defensive nature
I think that the commanders of US Army
are convinced that this is simply
possible and today the document speaks
about this enduring presence the
presence which is a fact and which will
stay there it is a rotational presence
is it is because this is most beneficial
from today's perspective to train
soldiers through rotational prisons by
having rotational prisons more soldiers
can come to a country be present there
look at the culture at the condition in
place in a given country so this is
beneficial for this broadly understood a
development of the Armed Forces
therefore this is an enduring presence
however it is implementing this
particular way and we hope it's going to
develop 1000 troops mentioned by
President RAM today which is also the
numbers stipulated in the agreements
signed today is very differentiated it
is not one single unit we're talking
about special operation forces weird
about logistics component we are also
talking about the already mentioned
Division Headquarters so there is a
multitude of forums in which the United
States is going to be gradually ever
more present in our territory from the
military standpoint
and this will encompass different fields
of cooperation so we're not talking
about just when a single beat but we're
talking about a more comprehensive
cooperation I talk about logistics
health protection for soldiers in a
number of other elements happening
please remember that right now there is
this missile defense facility being
built in logic oval so talking about the
elements of polish-american cooperation
there are more and more of these
elements and the number is growing I'm
very happy with that thank you very much
let's see who do I like nobody that's
the end go ahead yeah mr. president
thank you I was reporting to you but you
can make yeah here we go
I was actually pointing to my friend
with that beautiful hat on but that's
okay all right you'll give up your
question mr. president you seem to
suggest yesterday that you are
essentially committing to not spying on
North Korea is that what you meant were
those comments interpreted it accurately
no it's not what I meant
it's what I said and that's I think it's
different than maybe your interpretation
I think we're going to do very well with
North Korea over a period of time I'm in
no rush the sanctions are on we got our
hostages back our remains are coming
back you saw the beautiful ceremony in
Hawaii with Mike Pence we're getting the
remains back there's been no nuclear
testing whatsoever they'd like to do
something I did get you know very as I
said yesterday a very nice letter from
chairman Kim and I think we're doing
very well when I took over as president
I will tell you it looked like it was
going to be war with North Korea you
know that everybody knows that and it
was going to be quite brutal a strong
force with the strongest force in the
world but that's a strong force and we
started off a very rough relationship
but I think we have a very good
relationship right now so we'll see what
happens I'm in no rush I'm in no rush
but there's been no nuclear testing
whatsoever and when I took over it was
nuclear testing all the time and
if you look back to the last four or
five six years but really go back
further than that no fairness to
President Obama go back 20 years 15
years it was really a very dangerous
situation I consider it to be different
now now that I made I may change if I
change you will know it very quickly I
will be very quick to tell you exactly
what's going on I may change but right
now we have a good relationship and I
think probably better than we've had for
maybe 25 years maybe forever you know
they've been there a long time the
grandfather the father the son and
they've been there for a long time and
nobody's done anything except me and so
we'll see how it all turns out I hope it
turns out well for you and for everybody
and I'll give my follow-up to Jeff very
quickly president Duda thank you do you
see Russia as an ally or an adversary
are you talking to me was that a set up
question yes of CHO I would very much
like Russia to be a friend of Poland
because it is a great neighbor it is a
country much bigger than Toland with a
bigger potential than Poland in every
single respect except for when perhaps I
believe that we have got a more carriage
in us that we are more brave more
courageous and are able to fight till
the end irrespective of everything this
is actually what we demonstrated in
World War two at the Battle of Monte
Cassino we demonstrated that in the
Warsaw Uprising we demonstrated that in
many other places around the globe where
Polish soldiers died to make sure that
Poland is free after the Second World
War this unfortunately it did not
happened without ourselves under the
Russian occupation but even then for
almost 20 years after world war ii there
was this anti-communist anti-soviet
underground which fought against the
soviets and those people were murdered
today they we call them unbreakable
soldiers we commemorate their memory
although they were dug underground to
make it impossible for anyone to find
their remains and so that they couldn't
have graves bill so we were always
fighting we always knew how to defend
ourself
nevertheless history was brutal towards
us we never had a great friendship with
Russia Russia was always looking out to
take our territory it was a partitioner
in Poland for 123 years Pella did not
exist because part of the territory was
taken by Russia poles were deported to
the east then came an aggression on the
right on the recently reborn Poland
which arose in 1918 from the ashes of
the First World War and in 1919 the
Soviet Russia attacked Poland wanted to
grab polish territory and bring
communism to the west of Europe it was
us who stopped Soviets at Warsaw in 1920
by the bravery of Polish soldiers we
defeated them at during a great battle
and then we chased them back to the east
and then they took their revenge on us
in 1939 by attacking us together with
Nazi Germany and murdering our officers
in cutting so madam as you can see this
friendship is a very difficult one today
we are in the following situation Geor
Russia attack Georgia then in 2014 at a
tactic crane and these are facts these
are facts which are belonged to the
recent history we would like Russia to
be our friend
but unfortunately Russia again is
showing its very unkind unpleasant
Imperial face and would not want to be
part of Russia sphere of influence and I
am happy that today we can speak boldly
also in connection with the military
presence of the US and NATO in Poland
that we truly are first and foremost in
terms of politics part of the West
because we have always been part of the
West in terms of culture we have always
been part of the West because it is from
the West from which we adopted
Christianity in 966 more than 1000 years
ago and since that time we have been
part of the west of Europe we have been
part of the great Christian culture of
Western Europe but we have to stick to
this West also in terms of politics and
this is what we wanted I firmly believe
that this is the biggest desire of
Polish people to be part of the West
also in terms of politics thank you that
the United States is supporting us in
this respect for the
excuse me and just to finish I hope that
Poland is going to have a great
relationship with Russia I think it's
possible I really do I think because of
what you've done in the strength and
maybe we helped also because of what
we're doing and doing for Poland but I
hope that Poland's gonna have a great
relationship with Russia I hope we're
gonna have a great relationship with
Russia and by the way China and many
other countries and we look forward to
doing things on North Korea just to go
back to the original part of your
question and we'll see how that works
out I I do want to say though we're in
no hurry the sanctions Iran China has
actually been helping this quite a bit
and despite our trade differences right
now we thought we had a deal and
unfortunately they decided that they
were going to change the deal and they
can't do that with me but something's
gonna happen I think it's gonna be
something very positive but we think
we're gonna get along with a lot of
countries that frankly did not respect
us very much because they were ripping
us off for many many years and then not
ripping us off anymore Jeff thank you
sir regarding China
what is your deadline if you have one
for China to make progress on trade
before you impose the tariffs on the
other 325 billion dollars and goods
well we're gonna be meeting President Xi
and myself and you know we have a very
good relationship but again he's for
China and I'm for the US it's a big
difference and we thought we had a deal
we didn't have a deal and I would never
make something that would be less than
what we already had we had China opened
up to trade that's a big thing they've
never done that before we had
intellectual property theft taken care
of and taken care of beautifully and all
of a sudden those things started to
disappear at the end after they were
fully negotiated but that's you know
that's their decision I think if they
had it to do again and in light of the
fact that we have 25 percent on two
hundred and fifty billion dollars of
goods coming into the United States and
unlike a lot of countries they subsidize
those goods we haven't had inflation and
you know they keep saying that the
American taxpayer is paying for it know
now very little and what it really does
mean is that a lot of those companies
that are in China are going to be moving
back to the US you have car companies
General Motors as an exam
well that built plants in China well
that doesn't work out too well when you
have the tariff wall up because now
they're gonna have to get through that
and they can't really get through that
so maybe they'll start building plants
in the United States instead I think
that will end up making a deal with
China we have a very good relationship
although it's a little bit testy right
now as you would expect I think they
really have to make a deal a lot of
companies are leaving China as you know
it's in all the reports and they go into
Vietnam and various other places and
they're also coming to the United States
to make their product because they don't
want to pay the tariff and there is no
tariff if you do it in the United States
people don't realize that you know they
say the tariff but there is no tariff if
you don't do it you know if you if you
just do exactly as I say you bring your
company back to the United States and as
far as Mexico is concerned which was a
very big topic yesterday and now people
are finding out that the reports that
were written were totally false we would
never have had a deal with Mexico
without imposing tariffs once the
tariffs were imposed and they've been
trying to make this deal with Mexico for
20 years 25 years the older reporters
those great reporters with the very gray
hair in the back you know who I'm
talking about they know exactly what I'm
talking about you would have never made
the deal with Mexico we have a great
deal with Mexico I actually think we
have a much better relationship right
now with Mexico because they respect us
again but you would never have had that
deal if I didn't impose the tariffs and
those tariffs were ready to go on Monday
morning and we made the deal on
essentially Sunday night and that extra
little page of the deal that you saw
that brilliantly I had gained such
respect for you people when I held it up
to the sunlight and it was closed and
you were able to read it through the
sunlight that was not anticipated but
regardless I mean you knew enough of
what it said and I didn't do it on
purpose but we have a lot of strength in
45 days if we decide to use that
strength maybe we will and maybe we
won't but there's a lot of power right
now on the border and I will say this
Mexico is right now doing more for the
United States so an illegal immigration
and all of the problems of crime and
other problems on the border than the
Democrats we can solve
a problem on the border in 15 minutes if
the Democrats would sit down straighten
out asylum which is a total mess but
very uncomplicated straighten out Asylum
and get rid of the loopholes it would
take Jeff 15 minutes okay thank you but
just my original question sir was do you
have a deadline for imposing the 300 no
deadline my deadline is what's up here
we'll figure out the deadline okay
nobody can quite figure it out and
president Duda if I could just throw on
your way as well you said in the Oval
Office earlier that democracy in Poland
was strong not all of your European
Union counterparts agree with that
how is forcing Supreme Court justices to
retire early consistent with democratic
principles and president Trampas is that
something that you support know some of
you base four varnas Bravo this is a
very complex issue and it's hard to
answer this question because a lot of
people in Western Europe I think also in
the u.s. did not fully understand this
problem because they have not grown up
in a country such as mine I was born in
1972 in a Poland which was in the
Russian sphere of influence in which a
career could be made only actually when
somebody enrolled as member of a
communist party and who followed this
people's power who was the supreme
authority and this is what was happening
for many years although as you know
ladies and gentlemen a Solidarity
movement grew people were imprisoned
people were tortured people were killed
during the martial law and after as well
be it openly or in a secret way and this
this was the reality of Poland until
1999 and now imagine ladies and
gentlemen that not so long ago a few
years ago I was surprised to discover
that in the Polish Supreme Court there
is a whole group of justices who were
issuing sentences as judges members of
the Communist Party before 1990 who were
even passing sentences during the
martial law sentencing people to prisons
Bay
based on the law of the Communist
martial law and when I was asked whether
the Supreme Court needs to be reformed I
said yes if Poland is supposed to be a
truly democratic free and sovereign
country if it is supposed to be a
country who want it to be for our
children for the generation who was born
after in 1989 then for God's sake those
people have to leave they have to retire
and this is what we did as a matter of
fact everything that we were doing was
aimed at retiring those people but as
you can see unfortunately although 30
years have passed they have got
influence the influence which they were
building after 1989 where they assumed a
new identity of an elite of a new state
so this influence is still strong this
is what I can say and let me assure you
of one thing the freedom of speech is
absolutely respected in Poland Poland
absolutely respects all constitutional
standards just as in the United States
the right to assemble the right to the
freedom of speech there is free media in
Poland there is everything that is
functioning in a normal democracy one
can announce what they think one can
demonstrate one can say what they think
in Poland people are not attacked during
demonstrations as it happens in other
Western European country police do not
use transients or tear gas against
people people can speak their mind they
can express that they're not placed with
something this is a right in democracy
please ask Polish journalists when was
the last time when was a the last
demonstration in Poland when some kind
of tension happened no it didn't because
in Poland we respect the right to
demonstrate and to express your concern
because we believe that this is one of
the foundations of democracy in Poland
there is absolutely free and adjust
elections all the standards are
respected so please ladies and gentlemen
come to Poland and see Poland with your
own eyes please do not repeat certain
stereotypes that are repeated in the
West Poland today has got quite a
Conservative government that is true and
this government has got certain
standards of action nobody not everybody
subscribes to those standards especially
people of more leftist views but this is
the nature of democracy so once you have
got one side of the political scene in
power and then people make a different
choice and another side of the political
stage comes to power there is nothing
extraordinary about that and this is
change that has happening in Poland but
when somebody wins the elections that
they have the right to implement the
program which they announced before the
elections
excuse me however realize that
implementing the program which you
presented in your election campaign is
not only the right but I think an
obligation resting on a politician and
this is exactly what is happening in
Poland March in Verona TV n a question
for both presidents mr. president you
said just a moment ago that Poland will
join the visa waiver program soon how
soon we think fairly soon we're doing
very well with it it's a complex
situation as you know but we're getting
very close we allow very few countries
to join but fallen is one that we're
thinking about allowing in so we'll be
making that decision over the next
probably 90 days sir will you hope or or
do you think that maybe when you are in
Poland in September you will make the
announcement I think it's a very good
idea thank you very much for giving me
that I thank you mr. president upon a
presidential mr. mr. president the visit
waiver program and appeared on many
occasions but then it did not come into
practice how optimistic are we about the
where it's at right now but President
Donald Trump I'm looking at these words
optimistic I'm optimistic about that
because I think this is the first US
administration which has treated this
problem in such a serious way and in
such a comprehensive way so both when we
talk with mr. president we the president
expresses he's deep care about that also
when I talk with a president Mosbacher
the US ambassador to were so she looks
at the problem all the time and I firmly
believe that in accordance with the law
binding the United States because this
is something that I want to stress very
strongly according to the law binding in
the United States by all the actions
which are necessary in this respect such
as today's signing of the agreement on
preventing and committing serious crimes
I believe that through all these
sanctions this if these our waiver
program covering poles with visa waiver
program is going to be possible soon any
way that it is going to be possible
before the end of the first term of
President Donald Trump thank you very
much thank you very much
[Applause]